kirstie alley is giving her two cents on
the academy of motion picture arts and
sciences new representation and
inclusion standards for best picture
eligibility
and let's just say she's not feeling it
in a now deleted tweet the actress
called the list of new requirements
a disgraced artist everywhere yeah
like i said she is not feeling it can
you imagine telling picasso what had to
be in his [ __ ] paintings
you people have lost your minds control
artists control
individual thought oscar orwell kirsty
later deleted that tweet and clarified
her thoughts in another
writing quote i am 100 percent behind
diversity inclusion
and tolerance i'm opposed to mandated
arbitrary percentages relating to hiring
human beings in any business
the 69 year old actress's earlier post
came just hours after the academy
announced their new standards
earlier in the day in an effort to bring
more diversity to the category
and as a part of its academy aperture
2025 initiative to further inclusion in
the entertainment industry
films that are eligible to win the oscar
for best picture in 2024
will have to meet two of the following
four standards
on-screen representation themes and
narratives
creative leadership and project team
industry access
and opportunities audience development
the new inclusion requirements which
will take full effect at the 96
oscars in 2024 were designed quote to
encourage equitable representation
on and off screen in order to better
reflect the diversity of the moviegoing
audience
and the academy called the initiative a
catalyst for lasting change
on their instagram page quote our new
representation and inclusion standards
will help ensure that best picture
nominees reflect the diverse world
around us of course these changes come
after the oscar saw white controversy in
2016
when the organization nominated
exclusively white actors for the second
year in a row
well the problem is not with the oscars
the problem is with the hollywood movie
making
system at the time then oscar nominee
and now winner viola davis
opened up to e.t explaining the
questions that the people in power
should be asking
to fix the diversity issue how many
black films
are being produced every year how are
they being distributed
the films that are being made are people
are the big time producers out there
thinking differently thinking out of the
box in terms of
how to cast the role can you cast a
black woman in that role
can you cast i don't know a black man in
that role the problem isn't even our pay
black women especially get paid you
could probably line up all the a-list
black actresses out there they probably
don't make what one a-list white woman
makes in one film
that's the problem you know you can
change the academy but if there are no
black films being produced
what is it a vote for
[Music]